[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre las implicaciones que
trae la renuncia del primer ministro de
italia giuseppe conte nos acompaña julio
l burato analista internacional doctor
en ciencia política en la universidad de
génova señor levorato gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 al no
alcanzar la mayoría de apoyo
seleccionado conte tuvo que presentar su
renuncia ante el presidente matar el a
quien aceptó este martes le preguntó que
desencadenó esta crisis política en
italia
bueno pues digamos que no es una novedad
la inestabilidad política en el sistema
italiano en lo que sucederá ahora como
ya se ha dicho durante el servicio es
que el presidente convocará
consultaciones
y de aquí probablemente saldrá una nueva
mayoría la mayoría de los analistas
están ahorita apostándole a una una
tercera oportunidad digamos para el
primer ministro el que cuente con una
con una mayoría reforzada digamos así
ahora qué camino le espera a conté para
poder sobrevivir políticamente digamos
pues como le decía eso depende del apoyo
que los que los partidos le darán al
primer ministro parece que los partidos
de gobierno el partido democrático
movimiento 5 este ya están apoyando al
primer ministro ahorita estamos en
búsqueda al primer ministro está en
búsqueda de apoyos externos de grupos de
responsables
para garantizar los números para lo que
ya se conoce como el contener el tercer
gobierno com o sea que es decir que
conte podría seguir siendo el primer
ministro de italia si claro muchos están
hablando de hecho de una crisis pilotada
en conté hace unos días ya había
recibido digamos la el apoyo del
parlamento sin embargo el riesgo era en
el día de el jueves
frente a unas consultaciones sobre
cuestiones de justicia esos esos esos
números no habrían sido suficientes
suficientes en el senado así que parece
que el digamos trató de anticipar esta
crisis resignando sus dimisiones pero
mientras tanto están trabajando desde
atrás para construir una mayoría más
estable y ahora con cómo está el apoyo
entre los partidos cómo podría estar
organizado el nuevo el nuevo gobierno
italiano cuando se forme
pues como como le decía a los partidos
de gobierno seguirán muy probablemente
digamos y la hipótesis de un contender
se dará seguiremos viendo el partido
democrático movimiento tiempo exterior
como las dos fuerzas más relevantes
probablemente el partido de italia viva
el partido de mate ahora en si vuelva a
ser parte de este grupo de gobierno
junto con algunos diputados y senadores
de otros partidos y se calificarían como
como un grupo de responsables para
garantizar el gobierno
en caso contrario en caso que no se
encuentren los números se podría ir
hasta hacia un gobierno técnico en los
próximos meses o directamente a
elecciones en este caso lo partido de
derecha la lega nord en el fatal y de
italia muy probablemente ganaría en
estas elecciones ahora cómo ve el
escenario próximo de italia
políticamente hablando con toda esta
crisis con toda esta crisis política ya
qué se refiere con ese gobierno técnico
pues con gobierno técnico me refiero a
que en italia como sabes está
enfrentando una crisis económica una
crisis sanitaria como otros países
europeos y encima este año para italia
es particular porque esperará a la gente
no a la reunión de los 20 países más
desarrollados así que es probable que
para cumplir con estos con estos deberes
con esta agenda el presidente encargue a
una a un a un primer ministro que esté
afuera del esquema de los partidos para
cumplir con estas con estos deberes
digamos así antes de irse a elecciones
en caso de elecciones como le decía los
grandes favoritos serían los partidos de
derecha y esta es otra razón por la cual
simplemente el presidente prefiere no ir
a elecciones siendo que nos estamos
jugando además con mucho dinero que
ahorita está por llegar de unión europea
así es julio gracias por estar con
nosotros en 5 minutos con aquí en france
24 y usted es feliz día gracias por
siempre acompañarnos
[Música]